bonsoir à tous bienvenue au parlement
européen à bruxelles pour un nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo émission spéciale
aujourd'hui brax it or not track site
ce n'est pas galvaudé le sens des mots
que de parler d'un scrutin historique
les britanniques votent ce jeudi 23 juin
sur le maintien ou non de leur pays au
sein de l'union européenne
avant de retrouver nos invités on
regarde les derniers moments de la
campagne les partisans des deux camps
ont jeté leurs dernières forces dans la
bataille
dernière ligne droite jusqu'au bout les
partisans dans les deux camps ont jeté
leurs forces dans la bataille
david cameron lui qui a lancé le
référendum sur union européenne en est
convaincu ce jeudi les britanniques
devront faire un choix existentiel pour
l'avenir de leur pays
pour le premier ministre britannique
aucun doute la grande bretagne sur à
mieux dans l'union européenne à
l'extérieur
est ce que bruxelles a besoin d'une
réforme louis est ce que ces
institutions doivent s'ouvrir oui est ce
frustrant parfois bien sûr que ça l'est
mais la question que nous devons nous
poser dans ce référendum ce n'est pas si
j'aime le parlement européen ou non pour
être franc je n'aime pas beaucoup la
question que nous devons nous poser ces
sommes nous mieux au sein de l'union
européenne savent non plus en sécurité
si nous restons dans cette organisation
ou si nous la quittons livre en face
nigel par h
le patron du parti populiste ue qui n'en
revient pas un break site est possible
il veut croire que le scénario d'une
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'union
va garder l'avant ce qu'il avait jusqu'à
ces dernières semaines dans les sondages
ça fait 25 ans que je travaille pour ça
pendant longtemps j'ai cru que j'allais
devenir le saint patron des causes
perdues mais tout d'un coup c'est devenu
à la mode d'être re sceptiques et de
penser que les meilleures personnes pour
gouverner la grande bretagne ce sont les
britanniques eux mêmes mais depuis il y
a eu la sphère jo cox le meurtre de sept
députés qui a rapproché les sondages
le parlement britannique a rendu un
hommage solennel à la députée pro union
européenne un drame qui fait perdre du
terrain au camp du bric site en proie à
ses premières divisions dans les rues de
londres
c'est du fifty fifty il ya beaucoup
d'immigrés d'autres pays qui viennent
ici pour profiter de notre système
social
les problèmes de nationalisme de racisme
et xénophobie et d'immigration
tout ça ce sont de faux problème c'est
une ouverture en fait le problème est
économique
c'est l'austérité et pour en sortir il
faut rester dans l'union européenne
brooks it or not track site wervicq tes
résultats vendredi dans la matinée
voilà nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
soeur graham watson bonsoir vous êtes
britannique membre du comité économique
et social européen ancien eurodéputé
européen vous êtes président des
libéraux européens rob ashford bonsoir
vous en serez français vice président du
modem eurodéputés membres du groupe des
démocrates et libéraux ici au parlement
européen enfin jean quatremer qu'on ne
présente plus si vous êtes journaliste
correspondant à bruxelles vous couvrez
l'actualité européenne pour libération
depuis 26 ans autant dire que vous êtes
à vous tout seul une institution
européenne de lier croit 4e merci à vous
trois de nous avoir rejoints voulait
qu'on imagine ensemble on est le 24 juin
au matin et le royaume uni se réveille
avec la victoire du break 6 qu'est ce
qui se passe après la stupéfaction je
souhaite pour le moment rien parce qu'on
ne peut pas dire comme certains ont
essayé de dire il y aura la catastrophe
économique du jour au lendemain mais en
même temps il est clair que beaucoup de
décisions sur des investissements des
grandes compagnies seront autres qu'ils
auraient être avant il y aura une perte
d'emploi il y aura surtout une perte de
l'influencé qu'exerce la grande bretagne
sur la scène internationale dans
l'immédiat et à le problème de monsieur
cameron de se présenter devant le
conseil européen lundi prochain et
expliquer qu est ce qui s'est passé avec
toutes les dérogations avec toutes les
le mouvement qu'on a faits vers lui vers
sa position qu'ils perdent quand même
c'est très difficile et il ne sera pas
longtemps premier ministre
robert rochefort moi je crois à un black
friday c'est à dire je crois que les
bourses européennes vont dévissé de 10
c'est ce que c'est ce que vous nous
demandez de réfléchir
je crois que la livre sterling va a
chuté ne serait ce que d'ailleurs parce
que la livre comme les bourses avaient
déjà chuté il ya une dizaine de jours
lorsque les sondages donnaient le bric
sites favoris en fin sortant et ensuite
les bourses ont remonté je crois que ça
va comme ça se traduire par cela je ne
sais pas jusqu'où ça descendra je crois
qu'on va voir un week end très difficile
parce que tous les chefs d'état de
l'union européenne vont se dire comment
je réagis qu'est ce que je fais comment
je prépare comment ils vont se
téléphoner dans tous les sens et sur le
fond évidemment c'est à dire là moi je
me suis concentré sur le lendemain
puisque c'est ce que vous nous dites et
graham watson a surtout parlé des des
semaines et des mois qui suivent
et là je suis évidemment tout à fait
d'accord avec lui et malheureusement je
dirais puisque nos amis britanniques
sont libres de leurs de leur bulletin de
vote
malheureusement ce sera très mauvais
pour les britanniques mais ce sera aussi
très mauvais en tout cas dans un premier
temps pour l'ensemble des européens très
mauvais pour les européens ça veut dire
que le processus d'intégration
européenne n'est plus inexorable
encadrent excite déjà il va y avoir une
première bataille entre les européens
c'est à dire comment on va organiser la
sortie est ce qu'elle va être
douloureuse ou pas douloureuse donc
est-ce qu'on va mener
concomitamment la négociation de sortie
de la grande-bretagne de l'union
européenne et celle de son futur statut
aujourd'hui la thèse qui est majoritaire
en tous les cas à paris et à berlin
c'est qu'on négocie d'abord leur sortie
donc on coupe tout les liens et ça va
être quelque chose mais de compliquer
les britanniques vont devoir adopter des
milliers de loi pour remplacer les
règlements européens les directives
européennes
il va y avoir des conflits juridiques
judiciaires à les cabinets d'avocats
photo des députés britanniques 450
députés sont plutôt pro absolument un
objet magique vous imaginez la balle
interviendra autour de voir si ça va
être la même pas tout ça mais trop de
200 aliments mais infernal pour les
britanniques
en plus il va y avoir effectivement des
les marchés n'aiment pas l'incertitude
donc pourquoi les investir en
grande-bretagne alors qu'on ne connaîtra
pas son statut futur et ensuite donc
la question du statut qui se posera dans
deux ans alors ya ce qu'ils veulent
c'est en les pays de l'est d'europe de
l'est les pays bas qui aimeraient bien
mener les deux négociations de front
afin de rendre moins douloureuse la
sortie brittany et le problème c'est que
si on rend la sortie britannique pas
douloureuse ça va donner des arguments à
marine le pen ou à l'extrême droite on
va les camions et ça risque d'avoir donc
du côté juste pour terminer je donc là
l'idée c'est plutôt de rendre cette
sortie la plus brutale est la plus
douloureuse possible parce que les
élections français sont 2017 les
élections allemandes sont en 2017 et les
britanniques vont souffrir mais il ya un
problème même avant parce que pour que
le président se déclenche il faut que la
grande-bretagne invoque article 52 30
certains des leaders du président qui ne
veulent même pas invoquer cet article
donc c'est à dire ils veulent utiliser
la situation pour convaincre cameron ou
qui soit le premier ministre après de
demander dans une location exactement
des concessions de leurs partenaires
européens
donc il est possible que ce qui se
déclenche en europe et pire de la
situation que vous prévoyez oui on peut
même dire que puisque ce que vient de
dire drame watson c'est pour l'europe
pour les institutions européennes
il ne se passera rien tant qu'il n'y
aura pas la réception de cette demande
britannique parce que le lendemain pour
bruxelles c'est un scrutin qui est
interne à la grande bretagne
et ensuite bon moi je pense quand même
que je vois pas très bien comment la
grande bretagne ne pourra pas envoyé ce
courrier la question c'est qu'il enverra
puisque évidemment david cameron sera
obligé de démissionner ça ça va de soi
ensuite il ya deux ans et à ses deux ans
de négociations alors peut-être j'ai
toute petite divergence avec jean
quatremer
moi je pense que bon c'est le jeu
aujourd'hui ceux qui sont pour que la
grande bretagne reste ont par ailleurs
dramatiser cette période des deux ans
moi je pense que si la grande bretagne
sort est là comment dire nous ne votons
pas nous ne parlons pas pour des
électeurs britanniques
je pense qu'ensuite au bout de quelques
semaines ou de quelques mois tout sera
fait pour au minimum les choses ne
soient pas trop déstabilisés et
d'ailleurs n'oublions pas que par
rapport à ce qu'a dit jean pendant deux
ans la grande bretagne reste régie par
tous les textes européens dont on n'est
pas on n'est pas sans sans droit pendant
deux ans et après je pense qu'on sera
capable d'inventer s'il le faut des
prolongations d'un certain nombre de
textes avant de trouver de nouveaux
textes d'équilibrer la vie mais mais
mais ne vous trompez pas sur le fond je
pense quand même que si la grande
bretagne sort ce sera très mauvais et je
pense surtout et là je suis d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit jean c'est que l'union
européenne en face ça le continent pour
parler comme comme les britanniques
il n'est pas assez costaud aujourd'hui
il est passé unis il n'est pas assez
fort pour réagir d'une façon efficace à
cet acte qui sera très importante on
punit la grande bretagne y avoir des
volontés vengeresse et de la fin de
l'europe encadrent exit pour éviter
l'effet de contagion il faut que le
départ soit douloureux
c'est aussi simple que ça et c'est pour
des raisons de politique intérieure donc
pour faire d'eux les arguments
populistes et à l'extrême droite mais
aussi pour prévenir les autres pièces
que vous appelez un départ douloureux et
ben c'est pourquoi fort mais c'est à
dire que par exemple le march le à
l'issue de la période de deux ans la
grande bretagne aura tout simplement
plus accès au marché intérieur
elle sera un pays tiers comme le
zimbabwe et ensuite elle va devoir
négocier des accords et c'est là que ça
va être compliqué parce que quel type
d'accord va-t-elle devoir négocier parce
que dans tous les accords pour accéder à
un marché marchés tiers il faut faire
des concessions
or la grande bretagne l'a reconnu à
grand maman de jouissance souverainiste
et il va falloir expliquer ensuite au
peuple l'aco finalement les directives
européennes sur la courbure des bananes
des concombres ben finalement il faut
les respecter si on veut pouvoir
exporter nos bananes vers le continent
européen et services financiers
ah ben oui mais il va falloir se plier à
la réglementation européenne si on veut
exporter vers le continent européen et
c'est donc dans quelle mesure un
gouvernement dirigé par boris johnson ou
encore pire par nigel farrage sera prêt
à faire des concessions en matière de
souveraineté ils seront obligés de les
accepter
sur la question de la contagion moi je
pense qu'un tout petit peu plus
compliqué que ça parce que nous avons
cas de la grèce il ya pas très longtemps
pourquoi la grande bretagne aux
dirons nous pouvons sortir c'est parce
que la grande bretagne fait partie des
trois grands pays européens
qui peut penser je pense est une erreur
de raisonnement mais qui peut penser
qu'elle peut un avenir avoir un avenir
solitaire mais tous les autres pays
tous les autres pays à part peut-être la
france mais je crois pas que l'actualité
soit réelle en france et c'est le cas de
la grèce savent eux alors pour le coup
ils sont convaincus que sans l'europe
ils n'ont pas d'avenir
donc il ya eu un péché d'orgueil excusez
moi mais a péché d'orgueil de la part de
nos voisins britanniques de penser
qu'ils peuvent vivre tout seul mais ce
que je crois c'est pratiquement tous les
autres pays européens
au fond d'eux mêmes savent qu'il n'ya
pas d'issue il n'y a pas de possibilité
de vivre tout seul et qu'il faut changer
l'europe est forte dans l'horreur graham
watson la victoire du brésil
elle aurait aussi des conséquences sur
le territoire du royaume uni les
écossais pourrait sortir à droite risque
à l'intégrité du royaume uni mais ça
risque aussi avec ses parades ictoire
non ce pas contradictoire il s'agit pour
déclencher digital et parce qu'il est
personnellement je pense qu'on va voter
mais avec une très fine marge pour y
rester mais dans ce cas là il y aura
peut-être une vote en angleterre où la
majorité contre mais que ce vote et ont
emporté par les écossais les irlandais
et les gibraltar rien qui vont voter
plus massivement en faveur
dans ce cas là on est durs à la tâche
un nationalisme anglais qui est peut
être encore pire pour cameron en tout
cas je pense que cameron il est en
difficulté de s'asseoir vote pour rester
ou pour que les cieux deuxième hypothèse
la grande bretagne reste faut faire si
soulagement soulagement ça mais il faut
appliquer l'accord obtenu david cameron
sur le système européen en salle en
février ce sera un très lâche
soulagement parce que les questions
posées par le référendum reste intacte
parce que au fond qu'est ce que montrent
ce référendum
ces cas une perte de sens du projet
européen on a fait adhérer des pays qui
ne partageaient pas le but politique de
l'intégration européenne
on a élargi à grande vitesse sous
l'influencé d'ailleurs des goûts des
divers gouvernements britannique et
aujourd'hui on ne sait absolument plus
on en est et je crois que ça serait
l'occasion
de remettre à plat le projet européen
est de mettre en place
institutionnellement
institutionnellement cette europe des
cercles concentriques parce qu'il est
clair que la grande-bretagne à sa place
mais elle a un pied dehors et un pied
dedans mais il faut organiser ça pour
que demain la pologne la hongrie la
suède puissent bénéficier exactement des
mêmes accords il n'y a aucune raison
qu'elle se réservait à l'heure où la
grande bretagne reste il faut appliquer
le silane cameron oui et à la limitation
des prestations sociales pour les
migrants intra-européen à carton rouge
des parlements nationaux pour bloquer
d'éventuels directive européenne haarde
ait pas de discrimination de la city ne
sait quoi faire de la politique
faire la politique c'est appliquer ça
parce qu'on s'est engagé à l'appliquer
et en même temps mettre en place autre
chose qui est plus fort en positif que
ça en négatif mais c'est pas gagné
si jamais le oui l'emportent c'est pour
vous donniez une image assez pas un oui
ou pour vous donner une image c'est
comme si vous avez quelqu'un de très
malade de très malade et puis il y là il
tombe dans le coma on arrive à le
réveiller du coma et donc les médecins
sont contents parce qu'ils l'ont
réveillé du coma mais il reste très
malade donc le malade sort du coma mais
il reste très malade
donc il faut vraiment le soigner et pour
le soigner moi je crois qu'il ya eu il
ya trois choses pour mettre en place
cette europe des cercles ça va être
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça en a
l'air en réalité moi je pense que alors
est ce que j'ai moi de sortir une
vieille un vieil outil de cuisine mais
je pense que le couple franco allemand
est absolument indispensable il faut une
initiative franco allemande est ce
qu'elle aura lieu
je suis effectivement pessimiste parce
qu'en un électoral tant en france qu'en
allemagne
mais je ne vois pas de possibilité de
ressortir sans une initiative très forte
franco allemande
ensuite il faut quand même se dire quel
va être le quel va être le traité ce
qu'on peut comment et à quel moment on
va être mettre en place à un traité pour
essayer de dire comment et puis faut un
modèle alors l'europe des cercles c'est
quelque chose mais faut un modèle est
bon moi je suis plutôt du courant
fédéraliste ici je sais qu'il n'est pas
à la mode mais je crois qu'on est on
n'est pas très loin cet égard tous les
deux mais mais il faut il faut un projet
et ce projet ben il va être difficile à
faire émerger mais il faut qu'ils
émergent en cas de brick site
quelles pourraient être les conséquences
économiques pour le roi
muni l amende à gaza est allé à la
rencontre de deux chefs d'entreprise la
votent pour le breakbeat l'autre pour le
rumen le maintien dans l'union
européenne
reportage à londres
dans les cas bientôt l'heure du choix
pour les britanniques se passait au
chicago
si la population est divisée les chefs
d'entreprises aussi haroun el ouali a
tient un magasin de lunettes
il souhaite que le royaume uni sorte de
l'union européenne stéphane lofthus whif
fabrique des vélos il est pour le
maintien dans l'ue
dans la boutique d'haroun des paires de
lunettes à perte de vue de toutes les
formes et de toutes les couleurs
une bonne semaine on vend 50 paires de
lunettes toutes faites sur mesure et il
faut tous semaines pour fabriquer un
modèle haroun vent la quasi-totalité de
ses lunettes au royaume uni mais elles
doivent passer toute une batterie de
tests sur les verts les montures les
branches des examens inutiles selon lui
il s'en est d'ailleurs plaint auprès du
département de la santé britannique
qualité mais il leur est demandé
pouvez vous me donner des exemples de
personnes à qu'il serait arrivé quelque
chose en portant des lunettes des
lunettes qui aurait explosé ou même qui
les aurait tués ils n'ont pas été
capable de m'expliquer
ils m'ont juste dit qu'il devait suivre
une directive européenne pour ce chef
d'entreprise
l'union européenne est donc synonyme que
de contraintes
we have come from non on doit respecter
la conformité des lunettes mais aussi
des directives sur les déchets sur le
temps de travail des règles sur la santé
sur la sécurité alors que dans la
plupart des cas le royaume uni a déjà de
bonnes lois mais non tu as mis un autre
échelon de gouvernement un autre
gouvernement qui vous dit quoi faire
c'est un doublon qui nous coûte de
l'argent c'est and click iphone en cross
alors ce jeudi il votera lives pour
quitter l'union européenne
stephen lofthus s'occupe d'un style
différent de montures les vélos et ce
qu'il commercialise son temps peu
particulier
ça aura environ 45000 vélo à travers le
monde et on n'en exporte dans l'union
européenne à peu près 17 mérite un tiers
de la production et donc vendus dans
l'union européenne avec une
réglementation unique et salle arrange
bien alors pour stephen pas question de
changer maintenant les règles qui lui
permettent de voir ces vélos se déplier
à berlin paris ou madrid
si vous avez une seule règle qui
s'applique dans le pays dans lequel vous
produisez et dans les pays dans lesquels
furent exportés ça en devient beaucoup
plus facile si ça n'existait pas on
passerait beaucoup plus de temps à faire
de la paperasse
on aurait moins de temps à consacrer à
nos nouveaux produits à nos clients ou
encore à la publicité
ce jeudi il votera 8 mail pour rester
dans l'union européenne
mais en cas de brick site quelles
pourraient être les conséquences
économiques pour le royaume uni
tout dépendra de la réaction de
bruxelles
si le royaume uni vote la sortie mais
réussi à négocier un bon accès au marché
commun comme la norvège dont il n'y aura
pas beaucoup de changements en termes
économiques
il y aura toujours la libre circulation
des travailleurs le royaume-uni
contribuera toujours au budget européen
le pib ne diminueraient que de 1,3 pour
cent selon nos estimations ça mais si le
royaume uni n'obtient pas un bon accord
comme le canada avec l'union européenne
ou pire s'il ne devient qu'un membre de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
peuvent être beaucoup plus significative
avec une baisse de 2,6 pour cent du pib
ça ne l'est de 6 à 9% à long terme comme
dans tous les divorces les choses
pourraient se corser
selon un sondage de la chambre du
commerce britannique plus d'un tiers des
entreprises seraient favorables à une
sortie de l'union européenne un chiffre
qui n'a cessé d'augmenter
reportage d'elsa mandat gare avec le
tube chaude icetouch hidalgo à la
question fatale posée par le groupe the
clash c'est devenu l'hymne de cette
campagne alors l'un des arguments des
partisans du président c'est l'économie
l'europe ce serait trop de bureaucratie
paperasse de directive qui empêcherait
de travailler comme on l'a vu dans le
reportage
jean quatremer mais c'est extraordinaire
parce que on fait comme si les états ne
produisait pas de norme de règlement de
loi et reproduisent
le problème c'est que ce sont des normes
et des règlements qui sont souvent
contradictoires les uns avec les autres
et qui empêche le libre commerce
rappelez vous du temps où en france on
avait des voitures avec des phares jaune
alors que l'heure reste l'europe avait
des voitures et des phares blanc donc il
nous fallait deux lignes de production
une voiture une ligne de production pour
les phares jaune-uni de production pour
les phares blanc donc un terme aux nues
ni fils a évidemment ça rend les choses
plus simples dans le reportage c'est
fascinant
ce que dit le marchand de lunettes dire
est une des lunettes n'ont tué personne
oui mais un verre qui explose d'une
branches qui se cassent et qui vous
pénètre dans l'oeil et c'est yad'énormes
même en grande bretagne qui permette qui
sont qui sont applicables aux lunettes
et est il capable de citer le texte
européen non c'est simplement un
fonctionnaire manifestement incapable de
justifier qui dit ah bah c'est une règle
européenne c'est moi le nombre de fois
où à la sécurité sociale le
fonctionnaires incompétents me dit au
téléphone
oui ça c'est une règle européenne et fin
de la discussion ces vertus on est
vraiment dans le dans le passionnel dans
l'irrationnel l'incapacité à comprendre
ce qu'on fait pour avoir un grand marché
qui fonctionne au maroc fera c'est
difficile d'anticiper les conséquences
économiques d'un président pour la
grande bretagne et les avantages les
inconvénients et les coûts directs et
indirects
non mais toi et moi je n'ai moi je n'ai
vu personne et dire qu'il y avait un
avantage économique a parlé par à
cotisations non parce que la
contribution
vous savez que si si il y avait plus de
contribution britannique c'est vrai que
à priori aurait 8 milliard de plus dans
la caisse britannique mais comme la
grande-bretagne demandera à bénéficier
du marché intérieur
je ne crois pas une seconde qu'ils ne le
feront pas à ce moment-là on récupérera
les 8 milliards faux pas ça fait partie
de la base
il n'y a pas davantage économique et moi
je crois par contre alors là je vais
être un petit peu plus pervers je pense
que
si il ya eu cette montée du bric site en
grande bretagne c'est aussi parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on dit la zone
euro est plus forte aujourd'hui qu'elle
ne l'a été dans le passé et qu'elle se
construit contre la grande bretagne est
d'une certaine façon la grande bretagne
se trouve dans une position plus
minoritaires qu'elles l'étaient jadis
mais elle fait évidemment évidemment une
erreur il faut que la grande bretagne
reste dans l'union européenne
en revanche en revanche moi je suis vice
président la commission du marché
intérieur
oui il faudra quand même au fasse un peu
moins de régulation
l'idée selon laquelle la grande-bretagne
paieraient plus ce que ce qu'elles ne
recevraient de l'europe en groupe les
anglais payent pour les vaches
françaises
on ne peut pas être comme la norvège la
norvège fait parti du marché unique
donc elle doit payer les cotisations
comme comme si elle était membre de
l'union européenne
mais en même temps elle n'a aucune voix
dans dans la législation
si on et la norvège on peut peut-être
que se le permettre c'est un petit pays
qui est très très riche qu'une grande un
grand marché comme alan bretagne ne peut
pas se permettre ce statut il ya une
grande cause en faveur du break 6 et
l'immigration
les immigrés accra orpea prg après les
emplois pour les propres excite il ya un
chiffre qui a fait peur pendant cette
campagne c'est 330 mille migrants l'an
dernier arrivé sur le territoire
britannique un niveau record à la moitié
viennent de l'union européenne alors
d'abord sont les semis les immigrés
tiers c'est un des gros mensonge c'est
quand même extraordinaire
la grande bretagne aujourd'hui a le
contrôle total de ses frontières et ne
participe à la politique européenne en
matière d'immigration et d'asile et
mieux elle a réussi à sous traiter à la
france son problème d'immigration
clandestine le cancale et c'est quoi
c'est un truc négocié par nicolas
sarkozy qui est une folie c'est à dire
on retient des immigrés clandestins pour
les empêcher de passer en
grande-bretagne le lendemain du vote de
sortie je peux vous assurer qu'on va
fournir les bateaux pneumatiques pour
qu'ils aillent en grande bretagne c'est
plus le problème c'est le premier
britannique à l'intér d'union européenne
même chose c'est là que c'est un truc de
dax les eaux les grès à trois européens
les polonais les rues mais qui est il
jg en 2003 2004 qu'il n'y ait aucune
période de transition pour la libre
circulation des travailleurs intra
européen oui il a égalisé et la grande
bretagne ont servi beaucoup oui l'art
exemple pour laquelle nous avons une
relation forte c'est parce que nous
avons une économie qui marche très exact
en ce moment et si nous n'avions pas ces
immigrés là nous n'aurons plus d'aider
des hommes pour les vieux nous non plus
la possibilité de l'industrie agricole
agricole nous nous battrons mahjong
rendre mais c'est la réalité du chômage
a le plus plu de personnes employés et
jamais dans l'histoire
maintenant il ya et d'ailleurs c'est
assez fascinant parce que alors que les
investissements sont au point mort
depuis qu'il ya la question du bric
citent le chômage a encore continué à
baisser il est à 5% aujourd'hui il est
un niveau extrêmement bas
en revanche la grande-bretagne et ça
correspond à la géographie les
estimations de vote
et comme la plupart des pays européens
est confrontée à une question
d'inégalité en son sein d' inégalités
territoriales
il ya une grande bretagne et une
angleterre en particulier pauvre un pays
de galles pauvre également de même qu'
il ya en france des régions sinistrées
de même que c'est vrai partout et ça
c'est un autre défi
d'ailleurs d'une certaine façon
peut-être que là on voit d'ailleurs
comment ce choc la pub la logique
nationale est logique européenne
l'europe a su a su parfaitement avec les
fonds structurels permettre à des
régions des pays nouvellement entrant à
chaque fois de se développer
ça a été le cas pour l'espagne le
portugal il ya bien longtemps c'est le
cas aussi pour les pays anciennement de
l'est par contre pour les vieux pays
certaine façon là les vieux pays ont
leur propre logique interne et ils ne
savent pas bien et est d'ailleurs s'il
ya également marine le pen en france si
alternatif pour deux chiens en allemagne
si un monsieur farage
en grande bretagne c'est aussi lié à des
grandes difficultés
dernière question messieurs comment
l'europe qui est une belle utopie du 20e
siècle
comment l'europe est devenue au 21e
siècle a repoussoir pour une partie des
peuples européens escape à un décrochage
entre les peuples européens et
les élites qui veulent plus de
construction européenne c'est le
problème fondamental aujourd'hui en
europe c'est pas les partis d'extrême
droite où les partis populistes sur les
partis de gouvernement
si mamad est parti je parle des peuples
les partis de gouvernement qui n'assume
pas ce qu'ils font et qui passent leur
temps à communautariser les échecs
nationaux et à nationaliser les succès
européen c'est vraiment ça en permanence
donc c'est la faute de bruxelles
à partir du moment où plus personne
n'assume plus personne n'ose avoir un
projet européen
et bien c'est normal que les peuples
décroche françois hollande était élu en
2012 soit disant c'était un grand
européen
en quatre ans il n'a rien proposé il
s'est totalement désengagé de bruxelles
on ne l'entend plus le couple
franco-allemand aujourd'hui il est en
coma profond à cause de kippa cause de
la chancelière à cause du président de
la république française et c'est ça le
problème quand vous entendez par exemple
nicolas sarkozy candidat de droite qui
fait des propositions absolument
hallucinante à la chancelière allemande
en gros démantèlement de la commission
retour à l'europe des nations les
nations face on pourrait on croirait
entendre boris johnson eh bien vous
comprenez que les peuples décroche très
rapidement mais sur un an il faudrait
modifier le rapport entre les peuples et
l'europe de façon à retrouver l'appui un
des peuples européens comment on fait
non mais on l'a dit tout à leur
initiative nouveau traité mais pour
conclure moi je voudrais en tout cas
dire que même si nous vivons une période
difficile en ce moment je suis convaincu
que le projet européen rebondira il
rebondira je ne sais pas si c'est dans
deux ans dans trois ans dans cinq ans et
simplement parce que les peuples se sont
aussi des peuples qui font des enfants
qui font des petits enfants est ce que
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on considère
qu'il ya un million de deux de couple
erasmus est peut-être un million de
bébés erasmus c'est à dire de ces gens
qui sont partis pour aller faire des
études à part sur la robe traque mois la
convention
moi je veux dit que ce million de
couples ce million de bébés c'est une
très bonne nouvelle dans l'avenir de
leurs deux sticks break site ou pas de
réussite
moi je vais pas prétendre xxi avait
dégonflé jacques robert ben je me
dégonfle parce que vraiment c'est le
pot-au-noir il ya un cas possible
aujourd'hui au jour d'aujourd'hui de
dire en quel sens les anglais les
britanniques vont se prononcer en tout
cas merci à vous trois de d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
c'est la fin d'europe hebdo jean
quatremer je rappelle votre blog sur
internet
il s'appelle coulisses de bruxelles une
mine d'or quand on s'intéresse à
l'actualité européenne merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis vous retrouvez nos
rames a dit vendredi pour une émission
spéciale la résultat du référendum
si la bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires bye